for people who want to see some of those
images that you recorded or videos where
did they go
um they're all in the uh the niz
repository which has never been released
is there a plan to release it
um that's uh i i don't own that uh that
data set that would have to be the owner
of the of the data set and that would be
uh robert bigelow and niz i mean this is
a private uh was a private company and
it was accumulating private
privately held data
for analysis now all of the data that
nid's acquired over time
um is still on the nis website there's a
cached version of the nid's website we
wrote gobs and gobs of papers that we
published on the ned's website all you
need to do is google national institute
for discovery science wikipedia and you
will find a full uh cached version of
the nid's website there are dozens and
dozens of papers on the nids website
that the ned scientists
actually published on that website so in
terms of our published data it's all
available you know just happens
photographs of orbs are not available
but there is a very large data set of
published literature
involving everything from
investigations of cat mutilations
to investigations of ufo phenomena and
they're all written up in the scientific
vernacular on the needs website and
actually i looked at this website
yesterday so it is
actually available as we speak so if
people want to look at the raw data as
published in these uh in these nets
studies they're all available in this
cached website
i should point out the awesome
information and database is mostly not
public either we've given in our book
we've given a glimpse of of what was
available
as colin mentioned earlier uh bass
produced 104 reports that were submitted
to dia many of them with photographs and
charts and all kinds of evidence
that information has not been made
public
we hope that someday it will be you know
in writing the book uh we told as much
as that story as we were allowed to tell
it took 14 months for the pentagon to
sign off on our manuscript they went
through the this dobson process we did
have to make some changes that they
mandated uh specifically especially
about names of active duty personnel we
told as much of that story as we could
but there's a gigantic amount of
information that was sent to dia
that i know a lot of foia requests have
been filed
none of that has been made public yet
but we think it should all be made
public eventually